first a number of MPs are expected to
table amendments in the House of Commons
tomorrow that would effectively rule out
a No Deal brexit but others believe that
no deal is made big deal and one of them
is the former brexit secretary Dominic
Raab he joins us now former central
London it feels as if Parliament is
really trying to take that control of
the brexit process what do you make of
the amendments that are apparently being
about to be laid down on suspending
article 50 and also trying to block No
Deal well Parliament has already taken
control in one sense we've triggered
article 51 that's why we've been in
these negotiations and it's set in law
that we will leave the EU on the 29th of
March it's certainly true that it would
require legislation to reverse that
position but that would almost certainly
require the support or at least a
crescent to the government the Prime
Minister's been very clear on this and
it's not quite true to say I support no
deal I would like to see us go back to
Brussels look at the two crucial changes
I've always argued for on the backstop a
transition to a best-in-class free trade
agreement and I think there's still a
possibility that this deal could pass
but I think the British public would
want this done and dusted and therefore
we are leaving on the 29th of March that
set in law and I think it's unlikely to
be reversed perhaps the one helpful
thing I think the Prime Minister could
do is rule out extending article 50
people need some closure some finality
let's get this done and move on at the
same time though it feels as if there's
a movement in west minutes to try and
rule out no deal entirely what do you
think the consequences of that would be
well look I think it's very difficult to
do we've seen some of the shenanigans
over the weekend and attempt to try and
allow a super minority so less than half
of them please to set the agenda in
Parliament I think that would be an
extraordinary an undemocratic thing to
do I think as a reality check on this
it's very difficult to do some of these
colorful ideas that been floated around
and of course on the remain side they're
split you've got Dominic grieve arguing
in the Sunday Times that the Norway
option is is a very poor deal and he
doesn't support that and equally I think
there's much less support than is
perhaps magnified in the media for a
second referendum that would just create
even more uncertainty review back at
square one I don't think that's what
people want when they voted leave or
remain and the the comrades poll in
January showed very clearly that by
two-to-one people want this referendum
respected and I think whether people
voted leave will remain they want now is
done they want us to move on talk about
the economy public services we won't be
able to do that until we deliver brexit
so that's what we should all focus on
I mean Liam Fox for example has said
that if the result of the referendum
isn't delivered on it will unleash a
political tsunami do you think he's
right so I didn't quite catch that could
you repeat it please Liam Fox has there
written today saying that failing to
deliver on the referendum would unleash
a political tsunami do you think that's
right I was trying to choose my language
very carefully but I think that if
there's an attempt to reverse the
referendum stop brexit altogether
I think that will cut across not only
the Democratic mandate the biggest in
history we had I think also if you look
at current public opinion and how it
shifted by two-to-one as I said people
want us to respect the referendum I
think people's understand that's
basically a fundamental principle that
the democracy that we've got and I don't
want to leave on WTO terms I'd rather
we've got a deal but I don't think we
can let that EU hold us hostage and just
stubbornly resisted reasonable changes
so I think the Prime Minister's right to
send the negotiators back to bustles I
think actually one thing we should do
now rule out extending article 50 give
us some finality I think the team in
Brussels needs to change don't think
all the great work the civil servants
have done I think to close this deal
needs to be politically led and driven
and so taken into the control of the
politicians because this is a deal that
needs to be closed now and but I think
we should give it our best shot and if
not we're leaving on the 29th of March
and we'll make the best of it and people
will then be able to move on we'll have
the certainty we'll be able to manage
the risk but also be able to grasp the
huge opportunities that breaks it and
get on to talking about other things you
see you say that you would prefer to
leave with the deal but at the same time
you've been pretty scathing about the
Prime Minister's deal you're asking for
something that the EU is extremely
unlikely to budge on which is removal of
the backstop the reality is isn't it
that by not supporting the Prime
Minister's deal you're effectively
allowing other MPs to try and soften
brexit and potentially even stop brexit
altogether
that sounds like the spin the whips
we're putting around before the vote but
the reality is the vast you know this is
the biggest defeat on any vote in
parliamentary history
so obviously the deal needs to be
changed it's going to get through and we
should go back in good faith and keep
the arm of friendship extended with our
EU partners and neighbors and I think
there is still an opportunity there
Michel Barnier Donald Tusk who said we
need to know now what the Brits need
what they want so let's set that out but
of course if they're basically saying no
that they will not accept any changes
which would resolve the fatal flaws in
the deal that was put to Parliament then
we would leave on WTO terms at least as
a transition I think as an independent
third country would actually return to
the ghost
reasonably swiftly and have stronger
negotiating linkage but we can't allow
is either the e to bully assault for
them to call all the shots I mean one of
the things that you've been pretty
consistent in your Christmas involved is
the back stop it's a big deal for brexit
is like yourself also the deep here
Arlene Foster have said this week I
don't think the prime minister even
asked to get rid of the backstop now you
were Brett's at Sakura tree during that
part of the negotiation so did you or
the prime minister asked to get rid of
the backstop as you know from when I
resigned I had been struggling to
persuade the prime minister that we
would need an exit mechanism but the
right thing to do is have that debate
and cabinet for five hours I set out my
views very clearly I've made it clear
since July there was an opportunity to
address this issue and that it would be
necessary to put a good deal to the
country but also for a practical matter
to get it through politics I think I
told you so
did you ask to use me did you ask the EU
oh of course I raised it in July with
Michel Barnier who accepted then that
the the backstop would have to be short
but unfortunately I think after that we
didn't follow up and I argued very
strongly that we should do we should
have been resolute on this point and
look it's late in the day now but we
should go back and have that argument
and make it clear in there because I
think there is some focusing of EU Minds
I'm not sure it to be enough to get the
changes we need but there is some
focusing on EU Minds about the
consequences for leaving with on WTO
terms for them it's not the optimum
solution the optimal solution
do what we can't allow it's a limb to
blackmail us into a bad deal so you
talked about the some of the
consequences of leaving or WTO towns I
mean you said that no deal would have
some short-term risks I mean what are
those risks can you spell it out because
people worried
well there's a range of wrists and I
said to out it over the summer with a
speech there's the the risk of course
that we would have friction at the
border in fairness the French
authorities including the deputy mayor
of Calais has reacted very robustly and
saying no we're going to keep the trade
flowing because we don't want to lose
that vital business to the Belgian ports
and the Dutch ports there are also
issues and we already have them there's
an issue in the media at the moment
about the insecurity of supply of
medicines but not Hancock the health
secretary has said that he's got the
preparations in the plans in place and
of course put bricks to decide we
already have stockpiling for hundreds of
medicines each year because of the risk
to the supply route so I think there are
some short-term risk for say three to
six months but they're manageable the
advantage of course if we did end up
leaving on WTO terms and I said that's
not like a third outcome is it
immediately sees the opportunities to
take back control over our laws our
borders to have an independent free
trade global free trade policy around
the world and I think for the public
brexit will be delivered we could move
on and I think whether you voted leave
or remain I think there's a huge
appetite just to get on and deliver this
now now you gave a pretty wide-ranging
speech this week you touched on lots of
subjects brexit of course they're
improving competition energy markets tax
rates shareholder power I mean if it
looks like a Lucia pitch and it smells
like a leadership pitch it is leadership
pitch right know what I'm trying to do
is for me I think you're right to raise
the issue of risk but we talked so much
about with doom and gloom about the
risks and the downside of exit
we've lost the vision we've lost the
optimism the hope that fired up 17
million people plus to vote for the
biggest Democratic mandate in our
history what I want to say that is who a
positive optimistic post brexit brexit
vision for the UK is for its for the
consumers who get cheaper prices it's
for the workers because of the growth
markets of the future from Latin America
to Asia and also said we should take
some domestic decisions like cutting
national insurance for workers on the
lowest and middle income and I think if
we had a positive vision for brexit not
just taking it as some kind of a
risk management exercise I think
actually people have more confidence
that there's some direction to our
headed okay definitely not a leadership
pitch they know that's come through loud
and clear and do you think Therese may
will still be Prime Minister next
Christmas look I don't know what's going
to happen I want to support this Prime
Minister getting brexit over the line I
think we've got a massive decision ahead
of us and I think your viewers would
think you can win self indulgent for
anyone to be focusing on any of that
stuff now I think we've got limited time
so let's put ourselves in the best
position both in terms of a negotiated
deal but also if the EU resists all
reasonable offers the WTO transition if
we do that we'll be in a good place and
we can worry about all the rest of that
stuff after that exactly yeah I think
anyone would argue with you that we've
got limited time left and one MP I said
to me this week that there is the
potential for a deal to be done but
Theresa Meers possibly the worst person
to try and get that deal done do you
think she has got the the skills to be
able to bring enough and piece together
to get behind her grexit deal I do think
the government as a whole in the Prime
Minister must be part of that means to
listen more we've walked in or the
government's walked into the biggest
parliamentary defeat in history and and
it was something that wasn't just
predictable it was predicted I gave that
advice it was given by others inside the
cabinet and amongst the ranks but then
peas but it's all very easy to crow it's
a difficult situation the people have
different views on all sides I think the
best thing now is to keep it relatively
simple the legislation is there so we
will leave on the 29th of March on this
it's reversed and that can't be done
without the Prime Minister decision so I
think she's got to go back and I think
actually this defeat puts her in a
position to go back to Gus's and say
look Parliament is not
we're asking for two changes they're
reasonably straightforward other people
that will ask for more but I think these
two changes would get the deal through
and if you don't want that then you need
to recognize your parts in the UK
leaving without a deal with you and on
WTO terms this deal is still salvageable
and I think come what may we will make a
successor brexit but we do need a bit of
vision a bit of optimism and we need to
be absolutely resolute from here on in
with our new partners